si está viendo este vídeo su proveedor
de atención médica le ha pedido a usted
o alguien que conoce que se someta a un
análisis de sangre para medir sus
niveles de colesterol las pautas para el
tratamiento del colesterol de los
institutos nacionales de la salud
recomiendan que se someta a un análisis
de sangre cada cinco años si tiene 20
años o más la prueba llamada perfil
lipoproteína en ayunas mide sus niveles
de colesterol total ldl también conocido
como colesterol malo
hdl también conocido como colesterol
bueno
y un tipo de grasa en su sangre llamada
triglicéridos
durante esta evaluación se le tomará una
muestra de sangre después de no haber
comido durante 9 y 12 horas ayunar es
importante para asegurar resultados
precisos en la prueba el objetivo del
colesterol total debe ser menor a 200
miligramos por decilitro
para la mayoría de personas el hdl ideal
o colesterol bueno debe ser de 60 o más
el l dl ideal o colesterol malo debe ser
menor a 100 y los triglicéridos en
ayunas deben ser menores a 150
si usted tiene niveles altos de
colesterol en la sangre tiene un riesgo
mayor de desarrollar una enfermedad
cardíaca en la enfermedad cardíaca los
vasos sanguíneos llamados arterias
coronarias se estrechan o bloquean con
una sustancia cerosa que contiene
colesterol llamada placa
con el tiempo la placa puede reducir o
bloquear la corriente sanguínea rica en
oxígeno que se dirige a su miocardio y
causar un ataque cardíaco existen varios
factores de riesgo para las enfermedades
cardíacas los factores de riesgo que
usted puede controlar incluyen altos
niveles de colesterol y triglicéridos en
la sangre presión arterial alta
diabetes pre diabetes
sobrepeso u obesidad
fumar
falta de actividad física
una dieta poco saludable
y estrés los factores de riesgo que
usted no puede controlar incluyen edad
género
e historia familiar de enfermedades
cardíacas
si usted ya tiene una enfermedad
cardíaca y factores de riesgo múltiples
o graves su médico puede reducir su
objetivo de ldl a menos de 70 su
objetivo específico puede variar
dependiendo en la situación de su salud
pregúntele a su médico cuáles deben ser
los objetivos de los lípidos